I think out of the gate the first thing
I have to say is that music videos and
legends is so powerful it really really
is but I understand there's there's
different meanings behind this this song
yeah and when you wrote it to where we
kind of see it now talk a little bit
about that yeah I mean I wrote it about
two years ago when I was going through a
breakup and I wrote it from the
perspective of like wanting to look back
on that relationship with love and not
be angry or bitter but like really be
able to move on from that and be happy
and the one thing to say it's another
thing to do 200%
yeah but writing always kind of helps me
get there so that's why I wrote it and
then I realized that it's kind of not
just a breakup song it's just about loss
but it's also about love and and so we
wanted this music video to kind of show
a bigger depth of the lyric so it shows
like a very tragic loss and and
hopefully people just hear the song
differently when they see it yeah and
kind of leave you with appreciate every
moment that I absolutely just watching
it I love your people yes love your PL
absolutely yeah so you've written over
200 songs for this upcoming album how do
you take 200 songs and Whittle it down
to what we're all going to hear it's
hard it's really hard I think for me I
just had to like figure out what the
next chapter of what I wanted to say was
right like the first time my first
record I really just wanted to be like
an introduction so like I had the songs
about like yeah being underage I had
songs about my parents divorce I had
songs about my first crush I mean just
everything that you could kind of like
like shaking your hand saying hello
that's kind of what that was and this
one is much more like in depth and has a
lot more heart and a lot more heartbreak
in it and it's been really fun to like
challenge myself to get really down into
that write about it hmm
so when you're picking those however
many songs and who do you run it by
who's your person is that your family is
it a girlfriend is it the label like how
do you do that or do you yes I play my
song for everyone like my friends in and
out of the music industry obviously my
team but I really I really always want
to trust my gut that's kind of always
how I've worked and so
at the end of the day like I always
listen everyone's opinions but like if I
feel like it supposed to be on there
it's usually on and you know yeah you're
touring right now with our friends Lady
Antebellum how's that going good how
they're good it's awesome I mean
Hillary's like my big sister I've known
her for years and she's really been like
a big mentor to me I'm said to be able
to be on the road with her is amazing
and then you watch their show and it's
like 90 minutes of hits right over and
over again and it's crazy and really
inspiring do you learn anything from
them I mean as you're watching yeah I
think just how to like talk to audiences
like every every tour that I've been a
part of it's so different I toured a
flat last summer and then Thomas Rhett
earlier this year and now Lady a and
every crowds been so different but
watching how they interact with them has
been really impressive you're 23 years
old Yeah right I'm again well you're a
kid but my goodness like you're doing so
many wonderful amazing things such a
young age do you ever pinch yourself and
say wow look where I am right now and I
have so much further to go I have this
habit of like keeping my head down and
just going because when I like look up
and like let think so again I get really
overwhelmed okay um so I've learned that
I work best when I just like sprint and
do a bunch of stuff and then have like a
week off and then I'm like ah like a
Grammy what does happen sorry but I
can't think about it while it's
happening because I get really
overwhelmed you do yeah nervous on stage
or more so on stage at like an award
show I get different when you're with
your fans on stage and then when you're
at an award show I said yes totally I
mean I'm pretty nervous all the time but
especially for award shows and like Opry
and that kind of stuff oh yeah all
things make you nervous yeah yeah who do
you look up to the most I suppose in the
country music genre or any genre really
because everything's mixing so much
decent yeah totally my three icons are
Britney Shania and Taylor yes
that's like what I learned everything
from what do you think of Shania coming
out with her latest album I mean she's a
queen she's queen I haven't heard the
whole record yet but um her sing was
amazing and she's amazing and I've
gotten to know her a bit over the last
few months and you know it's really
interesting when you see someone at that
level